the land is ever-changing in these river
islands of Assam the rivers can swallow
up one area and leave another exposed
for the people who live here it means
they have to be ready to move Journal
Upton is 83 he and his family have been
displaced eight times six of them were
left out of a Sam's draft list of Indian
citizens last year moving so many times
has only raised suspicions they suspect
us as Bangladeshis if we were really
Bangladeshis why would we live here how
do we have these papers why do they keep
harassing us it's unbearable Assam has
seen waves of immigration since the
early 20th century and has fought a long
battle to preserve its land and its
ethnic identity in 1979 a student-led
movement began a campaign against those
who had considered foreigners or
Outsiders and nearly four years later
things came to a head right here in
Delhi nearly 2,000 Muslims were killed
in just six hours by a mob in Delhi and
surrounding areas in central Assam 75
year old hazel Hawkes all five members
of his family murdered any official
paperwork he had was burnt along with
his home it meant he's had to find
replacement copies of important personal
documentation today his son and grandson
are struggling to prove they are Indian
my mother was killed my sons were killed
I can't eat and sleep when I think about
what happened why are they still
persecuting us what have we done
for more than 40 years the Assam
Students Union has been fighting for
political and economic rights of the
indigenous Assamese it wants all those
it considers foreigners to leave both
Hindus and Muslims we couldn't feel like
a second-class citizen in our own own
Madeleine how we can those who are
propagating for human rights we like to
tell them we have accepted a load from
forty to seventy one for now a cloud of
uncertainty hangs over more than 1.9
million people in a Sam who still don't
know if officially they'll be recognised
as Indian citizens